monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues dont nous poursuivons les
auditions de la mission d'information
que notre commission a décidé de
constituer sur la création du fond
Marianne la sélection des projets
subventionnés le contrôle de leur
exécution et les résultats obtenus au
regard des objectifs du fond cette
mission d'information a obtenu du Sénat
de bénéficier des prérogatives des
commissions d'enquêtes monsieur Lafitte
d'abord on vous accueillant veuillez
nous excuser pour le retard prix dans
votre audition bien entendu remercions
de votre compréhension
vous êtes magistrats monsieur Lafitte et
secrétaire général adjoint donc du
comité interministériel de prévention de
la délinquance et de la radicalisation à
ce titre vous avez participé au contrôle
de l'exécution de fond Marianne votre
audition nous est donc apparue
complémentaire à celle de Monsieur
Gravel
avant néanmoins d'évoquer la phase de
contrôle nous avons relevé que vous ne
faisiez pas partie du comité de
sélection des projets est-ce que vous
savez comment la composition de ce
comité a été arrêtée y a-t-il une raison
pour laquelle on en fassiez pas partie
d'un faisiez pas parti
est-ce que vous aviez tout de même
participer à la sélection des projets
et plus généralement qu'elle était votre
rôle dans la préparation de ces
opérations liées au fond de mariage
avant de vous donner la parole pour un
bref propos liminaire et pour répondre à
ses premières questions si vous le
voulez bien je rappelle que seuls les
membres de la commission des finances
peuvent intervenir lors de cette
audition pour interroger la personne
auditionner cette audition est par
ailleurs diffusée vous le savez en
direct sur le site internet du Sénat
elle fera également l'objet d'un compte
rendu publié
enfin je rappelle comme faut témoignage
devant une commission d'enquête et
passible de sanction pénale
je rappelle ça magistral excusez-moi je
vais pas plus loin
je vous invite donc monsieur secretaire
général adjoint après tes serments de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
devait la main droite et dites je le
jure
je le jure je vous remercie je vous
laisse à présent la parole
en quelques minutes si vous êtes
président
à vos questions limées si je puis dire
la réponse est ouverte
vous m'entendez
en quelque sorte je vais répondre à ces
brièvement puisque en fait ma réponse
est négative
je n'ai pas participé à la préparation
en tout cas la rédaction je viendrai
après sur le mot préparation mais à la
rédaction de ce qui était ensuite
l'appel à projet
je n'ai pas participé vous l'avez
indiqué à la fin à la définition de la
composition du comité de sélection et je
n'ai pas non plus participé au comité de
sélection et ça je pense que vous l'avez
effectivement tout à fait identifié
alors je ne sais pas je peux pas vous
donner de réponse exacte précise sur la
raison de qui fait qu'effectivement je
n'ai pas eu à être associé à ce comité
ou en tout cas cette phase de
préparation moi ce que je vois mais
c'est une pure analyse de ma part elle
peut peut-être être contester d'ailleurs
dans des déclarations mais c'est comme
ça que je vois les choses c'est qu'en
fait étant depuis d'ailleurs assez peu
de temps bien chargé des fonctions de
secrétaire général adjoint j'avais été
nommé le 17 décembre 2020 donc ça
faisait 4 mois en fait que j'étais dans
ces fonctions j'avais effectivement des
fonctions essentiellement à caractère
budgétaire financier et donc je suppose
que dans la lecture que faisait à
l'époque le cabinet de la ministre
délégué l'objectif du fond Marianne en
particulier était surtout un objectif
qui avait une finalité de communication
sur les réseaux sociaux et donc une
problématique une thématique qui n'est
absolument pas la mienne sur laquelle je
m'exerce et je n'ai d'ailleurs aucune
compétence donc je pense que c'est
probablement la raison qui fait
qu'effectivement la composition que vous
avez cité que l'air je ne connaissais
pas je l'ai découvert l'occasion des
investigations qui ont été menées
n'a pas comporté en tout cas cette
dimension
ce qui aujourd'hui d'ailleurs de mon
point de vue mais c'est un point de vue
personnel peut soulever un certain
nombre de questions toujours est-il que
si je n'ai pas participé à la rédaction
de l'appel à projet en lui en lui-même
j'ai quand même et je l'ai vérifié parce
que j'avoue j'avoue j'avais un peu des
doutes deux ans se sont passés et
j'avais pas une mémoire absolue de
toutes les phases qui ont pu comment
dirais-je accompagner la
projet mais j'ai eu à participer par
contre à une organisation interne au
sein du secrétaire général quand j'ai
été informé et ça a été très précis
c'était le sauf erreur le 13 avril 2021
lors d'une réunion avec le cabinet de la
ministre c'est une réunion du comité dit
de programmation qui se distingue je
pense que je ne sais pas si vous avez eu
des notions du comité de sélection
concernant spécialement le fond Marianne
et ce 13 avril donc en réalité sont
annoncés par le cabinet non pas un mais
trois appels à projets
qui vise le contre discours républicain
essentiellement comme thématique un
appel à projet qui va concerner la
méridude la mission de lutte contre les
tarifs sectaires qui vient d'être
attaché depuis quelques mois seulement
dans ce cadrage général c'était en
juillet 2020 le décret est publié en
juillet 2020 et un troisième appel à
projet qui vise à promouvoir des actions
de lutte contre les atteintes et la
dignité humaine c'est comme ça que c'est
présenté sa vise en particulier des
dispositifs en tout cas c'est comme ça
que c'est évoqué qui par exemple lutte
contre les mariages forcés c'est comme
ça que c'est présenté cet appel à projet
n'aura jamais lieu je vous précise il y
a aucune traduction budgétaire il va pas
avoir de traduction non plus politique
et il va pas être annoncé publiquement
en tout cas il est évoqué ce jour-là et
donc le 13 avril 2021 étant informé de
ce projet puisque là c'est vraiment
encore au stade du projet il sera
annoncé le bon Marianne en tout cas
l'appel à projet sera annoncé le sauf le
20 avril donc une semaine après en fait
à peu près
je prends l'initiative c'est moi qui ai
pris l'initiative je clairement de
réunir un certain nombre d'acteurs de
Steam paraître les acteurs qui vont être
impactés au sein du service je parle pas
du cabinet qui est tout à fait en dehors
de ce dispositif qui risque d'être
impactés par ces trois appels à projets
c'est-à-dire pour moi dans l'analyse que
je fais à ce moment-là trois pôles
métiers alors Paul métier je sais pas si
cette notion vous a été expliqué mais
j'imagine que oui ce sont en gros les
services au sein du secrétaire général
qui par matière traite de tel ou tel
domaine d'activité de tel ou telle
politique publique qui est confiée au
secrétaire général donc ça s'appelle les
pôles métiers par distinction avec le
pôle administratif et financier qui est
un pôle support celui dont j'ai la
responsabilité depuis donc décembre 2020
et je réunis à priori je pense les
représentants des trois pôles métiers
qui me paraissent de voir ou pouvoir
être impacté par ces trois appels à
projets c'est-à-dire ce qu'on vient de
créer il y a quelques mois ou quelques
semaines qui s'appelle Lucdr l'unité de
contredes républicains je pense que vous
savez dans quel contexte
l'autorité politique a pris la décision
de nous confier enfin de confiance
locataire général le soin de créer ce
nouvel ce nouveau service ce nouveau
pôle un autre pôle qui est qui n'est pas
un pôle d'ailleurs qui est simplement
rattaché dans la personne du secrétaire
général qui est la mililud donc avec un
acteur qui représente ce service et un
troisième pôle alors je ne sais pas s'il
a été cité qui à l'époque s'appelle il a
changé de nom depuis je crois qu'à
l'époque il devait s'appeler le pôle de
lutte contre l'islamisme bradical et le
communautarisme je crois que c'était un
peu près ça dénomination qui risque
d'être impacté par le troisième appel à
projet que j'ai cité qui finalement ne
verra pas lieu
et surtout je les réuni en fait alors
c'est très précis c'est je l'ai retrouvé
d'ailleurs j'ai tous les jeux d'ailleurs
le compte-rendu de cette région que j'ai
moi-même rédigé que j'ai envoyé au
préfet bien entendu le 22 avril donc
c'est deux jours après le lancement de
l'appel à projet fort mariage et en fait
moi j'ai deux objectifs parce que je
sens venir des difficultés
d'organisation et en fait plusieurs
difficultés qui à mon esprit en tout cas
peuvent surgir d'abord un problème
d'organisation et surtout de respect des
process
alors je ne sais pas si ce nom a été
cité dans les auditions il y a un
instant du préfet Gravel pour moi c'est
très important parce que j'en suis un
peu là en charge nous avons la
définition du process de distribution
des subventions publiques au sein du LG
cipdr
c'est un document qui a été élaboré qui
était une histoire tout ça en 2017
exactement tout simplement parce que
l'année précédente en 2016 pour la
première fois les crédits du fond
interministériel de prévention de la
délinquance sont confiés en gestion
directe au secrétariat général ce qui
n'était pas le cas avant
et en 2017
avec des recrutements notamment je crois
d'un secrétaire général adjoint à
l'époque qui n'était pas moi je suis
arrivé bien plus tard et mis en place
une politique qui est se mettait en
place à l'époque au ministère de
l'Intérieur qui a la politique de
maîtrise des risques de contrôle des
risques
et notamment en 2017 au sein du service
kenanotre parce que nous avons le FIP
à gérer on met en place un document que
nous appelons logigramme alors c'est un
document un grand tableau excel avec
différentes cases et notamment des
colonnes dans lesquelles en fait on sait
ce que j'évoque quand j'en parle on
définit qui fait quoi qui fait quoi pour
gérer le subvention en centrale ce
document était élaboré en 2017 il est
révisé en 2018 il est à nouveau révisé
en 2019 et en 2021 quand l'appel a
projet fort Marianne est lancé c'est
cette version 2019 qui s'applique
qui à mon avis n'est plus à jour
d'ailleurs mais bon ça c'est une autre
histoire sur laquelle je suis j'ai dû
revenir mais encore récemment mais en
tout cas il est à jour pour une agent
très précise c'est que entre temps nous
sommes je pense alors je vais pas
retrouver la date exacte mais je pense
que c'est entre fin 2020 et peut-être
avril 2021 quand se tient le fameux
comité de programmation que j'ai
évoquais tout à l'heure le cabinet de
Madame Chapa à l'époque délégué décide
d'élever à son niveau la prise de
décision sur l'attribution des crédits
par des subventions en centrales jusqu'à
présent le secrétaire général le
secrétariat général et le secrétaire
général décidait seul de l'attribution
des subventions avec les crédits que
nous réservions en centrale sur des
actions de portée nationale en tout cas
une certaine ampleur c'était le
secrétaire général c'est lui qui
décidait en réunion comité de
programmation en interne au sein du
service ces décisions
et avec l'arrivée donc nouveau cabinet
de la nouvelle ministre la décision est
prise à son niveau de d'élever à son
niveau politique donc la prise de
décision d'où la mise en place des
comités de programmation ministérielle
cette fois-ci et je fais des recherches
a priori le premier semble être celui du
13 avril 2021 je vais pas trouver trace
d'un comité précédent fin 2020 ou début
2021 je pense que c'est le premier et
donc quand l'appel à projet donc est
lancé le 22 avril donc très précisément
je réunis dans un certain nombre
d'acteurs qui sont des acteurs métiers
vraiment qui pour certains d'ailleurs ne
connaissent pas du tout la matière parce
que je veux rappeler quelles sont les
règles et figurent dans le fameux
logigram qui fait quoi
et donc je le rappelle qu'il appartient
alors je veux pas définir tout le
logigramme parce qu'il fait il y a 12
cases 12 étapes à l'époque qu'on a des
renforcé très récemment en 14 étapes
mais 12 étapes ou en gros on doit
définir qui reçoit la demande subvention
qui instruit le dossier qui doit
vérifier les pièces constitutives du
dossier qui doit ensuite
mon pôle mon service mettre en forme les
actes attributifs de subventions qui
contrôlent également ensuite l'exécution
reçoit les documents soit venant des
pôles métiers soit venant en termes
budgétaire des associations qui doivent
rendre compte c'est la loi de
l'exécution de la subvention donc tout
cela est défini or le 22 avril 2021 et
ça je tiens à insister sur les trois
pôles donc je réunis ce jour là
un seul agent
connaît la matière
c'est celui alors je ne sais pas s'ils
ont été cités peu importe c'est celui
c'est celle d'ailleurs qui va instruire
les dossiers du fond Marianne c'est
quelqu'un qui a l'habitude depuis alors
je sais pas combien de temps mais
probablement au moins deux ans ou un an
et demi deux ans à instruire déjà des
dossiers de demande subvention notamment
sur le contre discours républicain c'est
ça c'est son domaine c'est qu'elle
connaît et elle connaît un peu la
matière elle sait quelles sont les
documents à réunir etc par contre en
face sur les deux autres pôles alors je
vais passer rapidement parce que c'est
pas le sujet aujourd'hui bien entendu
mais c'est important pour moi parce que
c'est comme ça que j'ai vécu des choses
on a des agents qui ne connaissent
absolument rien la matière budgétaire et
je pense notamment à la migridude j'ai
un agent en face de moi qui n'a jamais
entendu parler de ce que c'est qu'une
subvention son statut juridique le cas
dans lequel on peut le distribuer
quelles sont les pièces à demander il y
a tout à fait
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
cette réunion a lieu où je rappelle un
certain nombre de rectif figurent dans
le fameux Logicom et un deuxième point
important pour moi c'est de demander aux
responsables de ces pôles métiers de
désigner un référent parce que je
pressens nous allons avoir des
difficultés alors je sais pas si ça a
été évoqué mais c'est aussi un plan très
important à cette époque c'est un
problème de ressources humaines
alors c'est là où se situe mon rôle en
tout cas dans un premier temps
c'est-à-dire une organisation interne
une espèce de rappel des process pour
que effectivement on évite des
difficultés ensuite de gestion etc
sauf que évidemment cette situation ne
puisse pas le sujet des moyens
disponibles et du contexte dans lesquels
se situe le fond Marianne
même si il n'y aura dans l'année 2021
que deux appels à projet formalisés ce
qui est exact c'est un une année je
pense que je me trompe pas dans les
chiffres c'est l'année où nous avons
enregistré le nombre record de demandes
de subvention à instruire au niveau
central
c'est des chiffres que j'ai fourni
d'ailleurs
mais très récent à la Cour des comptes
puisque nous avions enfin je sais pas si
ça a été dit une étude de la Cour des
comptes aussi assez six mois dans nos
locaux enfin notamment avec moi pour
l'aspect interministériel et j'ai remis
un certain nombre de chiffres de données
et en fait il apparaissait effectivement
il apparaît que 2021 enregistre
pratiquement une centaine de demandes de
subventions 98 je crois c'est le chiffre
exact alors qu'un des précédentes on a
été une cinquantaine les années d'avant
c'était une trentaine donc une année
record des effectifs qui sont en tension
notamment sur le strict domaine
financier danger la responsabilité en
fait le pôle dont je viens de la
responsabilité je vous le dis pour
quelque chose soit clair c'est deux
agents
un troisième qui a été recruté au mois
de mars mais qui n'est absolument pas
formé à cette matière qui ne connaît
rien d'ailleurs à cette matière là qui
gère le budget de fonctionnement donc on
est tout à fait éloigné de ce domaine en
revanche ces deux agents qui eux sont
formés mais avaient les compétences
totalement distinctes il y en a un qui
est chargé de ce qu'on appelle le budget
opérationnel le programme le bob racine
des crédits du FIP des façon à déléguer
les crédits non seulement au niveau
central mais surtout en préfecture parce
que je pense que ça a été dit mais c'est
très important l'essentiel du fond ce
sont des crédits destinés aux
préfectures de département c'est ça
c'est 54 millions fois je vais pas les
chiffres en tête exacts pour 2021 cette
année je les connais par contre en 2021
ça doit être à peu près 60 ou 65
millions au niveau tout compris la
notification de départ par le secrétaire
général du ministère de l'Intérieur et
c'est 54 millions qui sont destinés donc
aux préfecture donc l'essentiel est
crédible et c'est cet agent qui gère les
rapports quotidiens avec les préfectures
sur ces sujets là et le deuxième agent
qui est une jeune femme d'ailleurs
c'est elle qui va instruire enfin
instruire mettre en forme pardon les
l'ensemble des dossiers du fond Marianne
donc ils vont résulter de l'arbitrage du
20 avril mais en réalité du 21 mai
pardon mais en réalité qui met en forme
tous les dossiers les 98 dossiers en
fait de l'année 2021 ce que j'ai n'est
pas tout à fait exact et c'est un cas
tout à fait exceptionnel parce que je
j'avoue j'avais tout à fait perdu la
mémoire de cet aspect là que j'ai revu
en disant les mails que j'ai reçu sur
ces sujets c'est qu'en fait je crois que
c'est la seule fois que c'est arrivé en
tout cas quand j'ai eu cette
responsabilité de secrétaire général
adjoint c'est que exceptionnellement
cette année là notamment au cours de
l'été 2021 compte tenu de la masse de
travail importante qui lire déstabilise
un peu je veux dire les choses comme ça
le service l'agent qui a instruit les
dossiers du fond Marianne donc celui qui
appartient à un autre pôle qui n'est pas
sous ma responsabilité va accepter de
mettre en forme un certain nombre de
conventions budgétaires attributif de
subventions parce qu'il faut soulager
mon service qui n'est pas en mesure dans
les délais de mettre en forme
précisément tous ces actes alors il y a
un délai vous connaissez qui évidemment
celui de l'exercice budgétaire c'est à
dire que aux alentours du 10 décembre
chaque année la direction financière du
ministère à l'intérieur la dépassé nous
rappelle que à un moment donné ce clou
l'engagement des autorisations
d'engagement les délivrance et la
consommation des crédits de paiement et
qu'on peut pas dépasser les dates avec
le nombre de dossiers de l'année il
fallait évidemment trouver des moyens
pour résoudre cette difficulté c'est ce
qui est fait j'ai retrouvé les mails de
sa part où elle me soumet pendant le
mois de juillet surtout juillet août je
crois un certain nombre de repas tous
les dossiers mais un certain nombre de
dossiers qui vont résulter donc de
l'appel à projet fond Marianne de façon
ce que je puisse les contrôler et c'est
là où si je puis me permettre il y a un
deuxième aspect qui apparaît dans mon
rôle sur ces sujets là et qui traduit un
peu les difficultés de cette année là
et notamment du fond Marianne
c'est que
en fait c'est à ce moment-là que je
découvre le contenu des demandes
suivantes alors c'est pas tout à fait
exact il y a une exception
l'exception c'est l'association je pense
que vous avez en tête qui s'appelle
l'USAP
parce que cette association en fait a
présenté une demande subvention avant le
fond Marianne avant l'appel à projet
enfin en tout cas la connaissance
publique de l'appel à projet elle envoie
à priori je pense au secrétaire général
pour probablement moi c'est comme ça que
j'ai compris les choses qui ensuite me
retourne des documents une demande de
subvention
de mémoire je pense que c'est le 9 avril
2021 donc effectivement on est quelques
jours avant le l'appel à projet la
délivrance et ce jour-là je découvre
donc pour la première fois une
association que je ne connais absolument
pas et qui demande des sommes très
importantes
extrêmement importantes c'est un montant
de l'ordre de mémoire 635000 euros
ce qui est quand même surprend je lui
dis clairement et je fais un mail en
réponse ce qui me surprend parce que ça
nous sommes quand même considérable et
surtout une association qu'on n'a jamais
financée enfin a priori jamais moi je ne
connais pas du tout
qui est dans cette présentiel qui a
peut-être une certaine notoriété d'une
certaine que je ne connais pas mais en
tout cas il y a un indien point en
premier point qui m'a l'air de ce
montant et le deuxième point c'est qu'en
plus dans le budget prévisionnel qui est
présenté il y a un déséquilibre mais au
bénéfice de l'association c'est à dire
qu'il y a un excédent qui résulte de la
colonne produit et charge bon alors
c'est pas interdit je le dis au passage
quelque chose soit clair et on accepte
parfois sauf que ce qui est interdit ce
qui est autorisé plutôt c'est ce qu'on
appelle un excédent raisonnable
or là l'excédent pareil quand même je
sais plus quel est le montant mais en
tout cas suffisamment significatif pour
que j'envoie une réponse un mail au
secrétaire général en disant mais en
écrivant que ça me paraît inacceptable
en l'état association qui n'est pas
connue montant considérable excédent qui
apparaît dans le budget prévisionnel
c'est quand même quelque chose qui
problématique alors cette demande va
être examinée au comité de programmation
du 13 avril c'est exact et dans les
documents qu'on a revu récemment parce
que il a fallu rafraîchir la mémoire je
le cache pas il apparaît un montant
arbitré le 13 avril je dis bien pas le
21 mai c'est le 13 avril de 300.000
euros
c'est ce qui apparaît dans un tableau
que nous restitue après le réunion de ce
comité de programmation
pour des raisons qui peut-être ont été
commentées je ne sais pas il y a un
instant ce dossier en fait va intégrer
un moment donné l'appel à projet pour
Marianne condition que moi je ne
maîtrise pas réellement mais en tout cas
c'est une réalité puisqu'il va
réapparaître dans les dossiers qui vont
être examinés apparemment le 21 mai et
qui surtout vont être arbitrés et
retenus pour un montant de 350
000 euros exactement donc ça c'est le
dossier c'est le choix je me trompe pas
je pense ne pas me tromper c'est le seul
dossier dont j'ai eu connaissance en
partie dans son contenu avant la
réception des je ne sais plus comment 70
71 aussi je crois au total qui a reçu
l'agent qui était chargé de la réception
et surtout de l'instruction des dossiers
et ce qui va se passer par la suite et
c'est là on ne peut pas ne pas venir
c'est que en fait je vais découvrir les
autres dossiers au moment de la
formalisation des attributifs
c'est à dire au mon pôle aidé par
l'agent qui instruit les dossiers en
partie va mettre en forme les actes
attributifs alors je pense que vous
savez qu'il y a deux types d'actes selon
les montants ça c'est la loi de 2000 du
12 avril 2000 qui a été modifié en 2014
qui comporte cette disposition
c'est l'article 10 sauf erreur de cette
loi en fait il y a un seuil à partir
duquel la forme de l'acte est un acte
bilatéral
en deçà de 23000 euros le seuil est fixé
par décret mais la loi prévoit le
principe en deçà le 23000 euros c'est un
acte unilatéral c'est un arrêté et donc
le secrétaire général signe un arrêté
l'attributif au delà de 23000 euros
c'est une convention donc avec double
signature et contrôle aussi du contenu
plus exigeantes dans sa formalisation où
là il y a effectivement quand même des
exigences assez fortes de contrôle et la
plupart des appels de la fin des
dossiers de l'appel à projeter Marianne
rentreront dans la catégorie des
conventions ils seront au-delà de 23000
euros de mémoire il y en a deux je crois
il y a deux arrêtés et le reste donc 15
logiquement qui sont des conventions
et donc cette aspect là donne lieu
effectivement à cette rédaction et à ce
moment là que je vois effectivement
apparaître un certain nombre de montants
qui ont été arbitrés ils intervient le
21 mai et il y en a un qui attire mon
attention je dis aussi il y a des mails
de ma part que j'ai retrouvé que j'ai
imprimé parce que encore une fois c'est
la mémoire ensuite il y a besoin d'être
réactivé il y en a un qui je vois pas
lui CPPM cette fois-ci je parle d'une
autre association qui s'appelle
reconstruire le commun
où là je découvre mon temps relativement
important quand même avec une
association qui a déjà été financée avec
une petite convention si je peux dire de
39000 euros dans les conditions un peu
compliquées d'ailleurs fin 2020 début
2021 je suis arrivé où je découvre un
peu la difficulté de ce dossier mais
c'était pas un montant aussi
significatif et j'envoie un certain
nombre de commentaires par mail là aussi
sur cette association en indiquant
qu'elle est récente qu'elle a bénéficié
d'un montant significatif important et
surtout et c'est un des critères moi que
j'essaie de voir parce que c'était très
difficile enfin je sais pas si vous avez
déjà vu ce qu'on appelle les CERFA de
demande de subvention c'est pas très
facile de comprendre ce qu'on a derrière
le CERFA c'est vraiment il faut parfois
il y a quelques critères parfois un peu
significatif et c'est pas toujours
simple il y en a un moi j'essaie de
retenir c'est quels sont les moyens
humains de la structure quand elle
reçoit beaucoup d'argent pour gérer
l'argent
s'il y a personne c'est une
interrogation et c'est le cas pour
reconstruire le commun alors ça veut pas
dire qu'il y a pas des bénévoles
capables c'est toute la complexité des
associations il y a parfois des
bénévoles et des retraités ou que
sais-je qui sont des experts comptables
qui sont des magistrats ou autre
peut-être parfois des élus nationaux
j'en sais rien mais en tout cas qui ont
bien sûr des compétences c'est évident
mais quand vraiment qu'on n'a pas
d'information sur le sujet et qu'on voit
que et c'était le cas de cette
association les effectifs alors je sais
pas je crois que c'était un salarié ou
un 0,5tp quelque chose comme ça qui
apparaît dans le CERFA alors qu'il y a
quand même j'ai pu 300 + 300.000 euros
qui est 330 000 euros qui sont
distribués ça a l'air d'un petit peu
encore une fois c'est pas un critère
absolument diriment mais ça peut
provoquer quand même quelques alertes
sauf que la décision a été prise
évidemment elle était arbitrée cabinet
il faut l'exécuter mais enfin je mets
quand même en alerte l'ensemble des
acteurs donc le seul qui est instruit le
dossier mais aussi mon pôle en disant il
va falloir quand même surveiller un peu
cette association parce que il y a quand
même ce déséquilibre là qui peut poser
des difficultés peut-être avant
si vous voulez bien peut-être s'en tenir
à cette phase qui était un peu la
première partie des questions on va vous
demander quelques compléments on a eu
d'ailleurs copies de quelques-uns de vos
mails qui vont dans le sens que vous
indiquez mais vrai que le rapporteur
repréciser vous quelques points et puis
poursuivra si vous voulez bien pardon
monsieur Lafitte moi je vais
je vous ai écouté j'ai besoin de d'avoir
des clarifications d'être sûr que
on sait bien enfin j'ai bien compris vos
propos vous nous avez expliqué quel
était votre fonction quand vous êtes
arrivé finalement depuis peu décembre
2020 vous avez bien expliqué que pour
les comités ministériels de
programmation le premier étant a priori
dans la nouvelle procédure celui du 13
avril
qu'il y a finalement une procédure
juridique enfin administrative et
juridique très établie avec les 12
étapes qu'il faut suivre donc vous me
confirmez que voilà ça c'est la première
chose ça permet d'éclaircir vous nous
avez également dit je suis la
chronologie de vos propos
que dans dans le pôle il y avait en fait
peu de compétences en matière comptable
et budgétaire
alors on arrive j'arrive toujours dans
les éléments dont vous nous que vous
avez porté à notre connaissance
le fait d'avoir l'usé ppm qui avant même
le comité
de programmation et donc avant le
lancement officiel du fond Marianne
adresse une demande de subvention
au comité
interministériel d'un montant de 635
000 euros donc effectivement et vous
dites
je ne connais pas j'ai aucun
renseignements et le montant enfin je le
conseille volontiers et très élevé vous
avez même dit qu'il y avait ensuite dans
la présentation comptable un excédent
significatif
et ensuite alors sont retirés je crois
300.000 euros vous pouvez me
réexpliquer comment on passe de 635 000
à 335 et quel est l'opération qui était
effectuée pour le retrait de ces 300000
euros alors ce que je sais moi à travers
les documents qu'on a pu relire je
répète la mémoire n'est pas extrêmement
présente sur toutes les étapes l'avouer
c'est une décision qui a été pris en
comité de programmation ministérielle
donc le 13 avril a priori là parce que
je perçois et là mais dans un contexte
que je ne mangeais pas le souvenir il y
a eu effectivement une décision de
rabattre sensiblement la prétention
effectivement
le comité retient 335 000 ou 350 300000
je crois oui il en est il retire 300 000
voilà et il en reste je pense 335 il me
semble que vous avez 355 mais on va pas
je cherche pas à basé sur les sur les
montants mais enfin moi ça me paraît
assez cohérent ensuite vous vous avez
expliqué la procédure qui laisse la main
au comité jusqu'à 23000 euros puisque
c'est discrétionnel au-delà c'est
forcément une convention et donc ça
n'est plus discrétionnaire puisqu'il
faut une double signature
vous avez expliqué vous avez employé les
mots que vous avez eu dans des
conditions difficiles inversement de
39000 euros est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire plus les conditions difficiles
ou la
expliquer enfin quel était le contexte
qui des difficultés il y a une
difficulté alors j'ai pas je pense que
je ne t'ai pas présent à ce moment-là
parce que ça s'est passé à la fin de
l'année 2020 j'avais encore j'avais pas
les responsabilités que j'ai eu donc à
la fin de l'année on a eu en fait des
difficultés pour identifier le l'acte
juridique qui était à l'origine de la
délivrance de cette somme
qu'il existe je vous rassure je pense
qu'il y a pas eu de difficultés sur son
existence mais il y en a du mal à
l'identifier dans un premier temps et ça
tient à priori au fait que il y a eu une
décision je n'ai pas retrouvé la trace
je le dis clairement j'ai encore
recherché récemment j'ai pas retrouvé la
trace mais elle existe puisqu'il y a eu
une convention qui a été passée qui date
de la fin de l'année 2020 le document le
document lui-même l'acte attributif
c'est une convention signée des deux
parties donc le secrétaire général et le
représentant de l'association la
représentante d'ailleurs c'est le
présidente et dater exactement du 28
décembre 2020
or le 28 décembre 2020 c'est un moment
où il y a plus de crédit disponible
pour attribuer une subvention je ne sais
pas dans quel contexte elle avait eu
lieu mais en tout cas cet acte on l'a
fini par le retrouver et c'est le 28
décembre et en fait ce qui est découvert
c'est que on a des tableaux de suivi
dans mon pôle enfin vraiment service à
moi on suit chaque convention pour
savoir quand on délivre le premier
acompte quand il y a des acomptes et
quand on délivre le solde quand il y a
un sol et on trouve une trace
effectivement de cette cette convention
de 2020 je dis bien par contre il y a
une mention qui indique que elle est
basculée je dis c'est le terme basculer
en 2021 pour des raisons d'ailleurs
budgétaires strictement et donc en fait
on retrouve effectivement la trace de
cette subvention qui a été versée mais
en 2021 avec les crédits une fois que la
direction financière enfin le secrétaire
général du ministère nous a notifié des
crédits on a pu attribuer les crédits
qui avaient été dessinés l'année d'avant
avant on pouvait pas parce que
finalement qu'une libert sur le plan
budgétaire
d'une certaine manière je veux
être sûr qu'il y aurait pas
d'interprétation
inappropriée ouative une subvention est
attribuée le 28 décembre à une période
où il y a plus les moyens et puis enfin
il y a plus de crédit un peu plus tard
en entre guillemets on procède au
versement en disant qu'elle a été
attribuée l'an passé l'année passée
alors qu'il y avait plus de fonds en
gros c'est c'est à peu près ça ce qui
est-ce que j'exagère en disant que
peut-être ça limite le contrôle alors je
ne sais pas si ça limite le contrôle en
tout cas ça aboutit à une situation qui
est à mon avis discutable et dont on va
se rendre compte d'ailleurs plus tard
mais beaucoup plus tard trop tard
d'ailleurs probablement pour remettre en
cause d'ailleurs l'attribution c'est que
en fait l'action va s'exécuter en 2021
sauf que la convention d'origine de 2020
normalement aurait dû permettre
l'imputation des charges sur l'exercice
2020 je dis bien or l'exécution va se
faire en 2021 et donc les dépenses aussi
forcément et on a regardé les
investigations il y a quelques semaines
on a regardé si on a trouvé la trace
d'un avenant ce qui est possible on peut
effectivement ça arrive parfois et c'est
beaucoup arrivé d'ailleurs à cette
époque à cause de la crise sanitaire on
a énormément d'associations qui n'ont
pas pu exécuter en 2020 et même 2021
d'ailleurs leur action pour des raisons
qu'on comprend et il a fallu faire des
avenants pour prolonger la durée
d'exécution ce qui était logique on n'a
pas trouvé de trace dans ce dossier là
en tout cas je le dis d'un avenant qui
aurait encadré juridiquement la
prolongation et pour autant c'est ce qui
va se passer c'est-à-dire les crédits
2021 votre mobilisés
les 39000 euros je crois que c'est du
montant vont être attribués et
l'exécution va être fait il y aura des
comptes rendus le compte-rendu financier
qui est obligé obligatoire d'après la
loi va être adressée et a priori
d'action a bien été exécuté il
s'agissait de créer un site je crois
internet l'association a été créée je
crois en octobre 2020 ou en tout cas fin
2020 il s'agissait de créer un site
internet et de promouvoir un certain
nombre de dispositifs sur les réseaux
sociaux a priori les comptes rendus en
tout cas sur le plan strictement formel
qui vont être adressés dans le cadre de
cette action montre qu'il y a eu une
action conforme à ce qui avait été prévu
au départ en tout cas moi j'ai pas de
raison de remettre en cause l'existence
de cette action et sa réalisation
ce qui est compliqué c'est là le
basculement quelque sorte entre les deux
exercices budgétaires
ce que vous aviez fini parce que je vous
interrompue je voulais pas perdre le fil
de des différentes étapes lorsque je
veux dire simplement c'est sur la
manière dont on a on aurait pu alors
peut-être même dû contrôler en amont du
21 mai le contenu des demandes
subventions je dis pas qu'elles étaient
toutes problématique c'est pas du tout
le cas et je pense que la plupart ne
l'est pas d'ailleurs mais il aurait pu y
avoir un appui de la part d'autres
acteurs que simplement le seul agent qui
était chargé d'instruire je crois que au
départ c'est 71 dossiers qui sont reçus
c'est considérable on aurait pu avoir un
appui qui n'a pas eu lieu pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que tout
simplement enfin en tout cas moi ce qui
me concerne moi j'ai pas été associé
effectivement à cette phase de
préparation et d'instruction des
dossiers mais surtout parce que on a un
agent alors je pense que ça a été dit
mais pour nous c'est très important et
j'envoie maintenant les conséquences
c'est que on avait un agent qui n'est
pas directement dans ses fonctions mais
qui a réellement en fait apporté cet
appui pendant pas mal d'années qui était
ce qu'on appelle nous les référents de
contrôle
pour faire simple référent de comprendre
l'interne financier c'est un agent qui
est chargé de suivre tout le processus
de dépense de contrôler processus de
dépense alors en fait par sondage parce
que nous contrôle pas je le dis
clairement en totalité sans subventions
par an c'est absolument impossible mais
ne serait-ce que par sondage il a cette
fonction de vérifier que le logigramme
dont j'ai parlé a été respecté c'est à
dire que toutes les 12 étapes ont bien
été respectées par les agents internes
du secrétaire général mais aussi et ça
ce qu'on appelle le contrôle de deuxième
niveau et ça c'est extrêmement important
de contrôler la réalité de la dépense
notamment les pièces de dépenses
justificatives de dépenses les factures
les bulletins de salaires
or ça et bien lorsque le fond Marianne
est lancé l'appel à projet depuis
février 2021 il n'y a plus d'argent au
service il n'y a plus d'agent au service
jusqu'en de mémoire septembre 2022 je le
lis parce que j'ai participé à la
comment dirais-je recrutement de ce qui
me paraissait indispensable et ça a été
extrêmement compliqué de trouver
quelqu'un qui avait un profil de
connaissance du budget de l'État on a eu
énormément de candidats sur ce poste là
des personnes qui ne venaient
pratiquement que du privé qui était dans
le domaine de la banque de l'audit
bancaire des assurances mais qui ne
connaissaient absolument pas le budget
de l'État et donc il a fallu attendre
septembre 2022 pour enfin trouver
quelqu'un qui va rejoindre ce poste
qui d'ailleurs en ce moment est chargé
du contrôle de plusieurs des
associations que nous venons parler
notamment l'ueppn ok on a demandé de
transmettre toutes les tâches
justificatives en mars 2023 et aller
dessus en ce moment qui veut dire ce qui
veut dire que vous êtes
heureusement expérimenté mais vous êtes
fraîchement nommé
quand
peu de temps après le fond Marianne va
être mis en place avec entre temps
quelques difficultés là vous avez
expliqué les 39000 euros avec
finalement
un personne enfin oui une personne
ressource qui assure le suivi
vu que j'appellerai du contrôle afin que
vous appelez ainsi contrôle internet
financier donc absence totale de février
pendant 18 mois février 21 septembre
2022 puis vous avez la personne
visiblement également ressources dans le
pôle du comité qui est plutôt la
personne enfin qui a beaucoup de
compétences qui est également quitte en
fin d'année 2021 je crois mais je crois
voilà
donc on va dire qu'il y a des
il y a des indices qui tous les cas où
des symptômes je sais pas quand on le
voit après qui peut-être explique un
certain nombre de difficultés de celles
que l'on constate à ce moment donc vous
nous avez dit vous ne faites pas partie
du comité de sélection on a bien compris
vous arrivez après coup
par contre vous confirmez bien par la
réunion du 22 avril que les comment
dirais-je les directives le fameux
comment programme en 12 étapes est
appliqué pour l'ensemble des du process
mis en place par le format Marianne il y
a aucun en tout cas on rappelle
effectivement ces règles j'ai le
compte-rendu je peux vous le mettre à
disposition si vous souhaitez il est là
parce que le commandant
de bonne qualité mais en tout cas on
voit à peu près les échanges qui avaient
eu lieu ce jour-là mais en fait cet
aspect là c'est un simple rappel ce
jour-là bien entendu ça va pas se
révéler suffisant je le dis clairement
alors c'est pas le sujet d'aujourd'hui
mais on va dans la foulée d'ailleurs de
cette réunion je pense c'est pas dû se
passer au mois de juin probablement j'ai
partout exactement la trace mais je
pense que c'est juin ou fin mai on va
même mettre en place une formation
spécifique sur un agent de la mi-véludre
c'est pas le sujet d'aujourd'hui mais
pour nous ça nous a impacté il a fallu
former et on a donné des doc d'ailleurs
plus explicite pour expliquer à cette
personne qui allait instruire tous les
dossiers de l'appel à projet cette
fois-ci de la lutte contre le dérive
secteur comment faire pour gérer
recevoir les dossiers d'abord regarder
le contenu du demande de subvention ça
s'agit pas de la recevoir il faut
examiner ce qu'il y a à l'intérieur voir
s'il y a pas des incohérences voir des
absurdités et notamment ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure l'excédent possible dans
un budget prévisionnel ce qui arrive
parfois ça c'est les choses à voir où
l'absence de ressources humaines pour
gérer les crédits c'est aussi un indice
qui mérite d'être mise en compte et donc
on va la former cet agent dans un une
phase de formation il y a eu trois deux
réunions un document qui a été élaboré
etc mais c'est l'ami ville c'est pas le
fond Marianne le fond Marianne on estime
que enfin moi j'estime que l'agent qui
connaissances est en mesure d'instruire
ces dossiers malgré la masse de travail
pour elle que ça va représenter c'est
certain voilà voilà la situation
d'accord donc on relève néanmoins que
dans deux mails de l'été 2021 juin et
juillet vous vous interroger donc sur
l'octra d'une subvention de plus de
300.000 euros 330 000 exactement à
hautconsur en commun et vous l'avez
évoqué dans un une partie de vos propos
que l'association aux étonnez qu'elle
soit d'une création récente sans salarié
et a priori sans prévisions de
recrutement
est-ce que c'est de l'expérience que
vous aviez était ce une comment
dirais-je une première pour vous quelle
qu'elle a été
quelles ont été les réactions de des
destinataires de vos messages quelle
mesure ont été prises à ce moment-là
alors la décision était prise de
financement donc il fallait mettre en
forme et bien entendu une fois que la ça
c'est la règle budgétaire mais une fois
que l'acte étant décidé donc au niveau
ministériel une fois que l'acte est
rédigé est signé des deux parties c'est
un acte d'engagement juridique c'est ce
qu'on appelle un EGI en matière
budgétaire donc vachement juridique ça
veut dire que ensuite il y aura une
traduction budgétaire dans l'application
qui s'appelle chorus l'application de
gestion des crédits d'État et donc là il
va y avoir il va y avoir tout à la fois
l'engagement des autorisations
d'engagement les aveux 100% et la
délivrance alors ça c'est les
conventions qui nous sont propres la
délivrance la consommation d'une partie
des crédits de paiement et donc on va
délivrer l'argent malgré ma remarque
bien entendu parce qu'on peut pas aller
contre difficile à ce stade en tout cas
les temps précisé que c'est pas parce
qu'il y a pas de salariés dans une
association je disais tout à l'heure
qu'elle n'est pas capable de gérer il y
a des bénévoles d'une part sur
l'exécution même de l'action d'ailleurs
enfin c'est ce qui est prévu je crois de
mémoire dans le document qu'on avait
reçu qu'on a vu par la suite il y avait
non pas des recrutements de salariés qui
étaient prévus mais le recours a des
prestataires ce qui est assez classique
dans ce genre d'action où on rémunère
sous forme de factures j'imagine des
prestataires pour faire telle ou telle
action sur les réseaux sociaux ce qui
est effectivement la traduction de
l'action ce qui se fait au spa en
recrutant de salariés à chaque fois donc
c'est pas inconcevable mais c'est un
élément d'alerte et c'est la raison pour
laquelle j'avais indiqué je crois dans
un des mails concerné en je sais plus
c'est en juillet mais je crois que c'est
juillet 2021 que c'était ce type
d'action qui méritait justement
peut-être un contrôle a postériori sur
la réalité de la consommation des
crédits et notamment dans ce qu'on
appelle le contrôle de deuxième niveau
sur piège du justificative qui ne se
fait que sur sur des échantillons on
peut pas encore une fois contrôler
l'ensemble des dossiers c'est affaire en
quelque sorte une alerte
donc
ces choses là étant dites et les alertes
ayant été données
donc le visa est donné et donc
l'opération démarre
bien pouvez-vous nous parler de
maintenant de l'exécution de forme
mariage comment elle a été assurée après
la sélection des projets finalement et
les premiers versements de subventions
réalisées autrement dit quel contrôle
avez-vous opéré sur l'ensemble des
projets de manière très globale
avez-vous réalisé un ou des contrôles
sur pièces ou bien prenez-t-il une autre
forme
ce modalité de contrôle sont elles
identiques à ce que vous avez pu faire
dans d'autres dans d'autres enveloppes
budgétaires versés à des associations
comme le Philip
alors le contrôle concernant les 17
dossiers de l'appel à projet est
absolument identique enfin doit être
absolument identique et il a été je
pense de ce qui est fait sur l'ensemble
des autres actions financées bien
entendu la question de créer des règles
spécifiques
en fait il y a plus rien un double
contrôle
il y a ce que nous appelons nous le
contrôle métier qui est un peu le fond
du problème notamment pour l'association
reconstruire le commun c'est un contrôle
sur l'exécution même de l'action j'avoue
je n'ai sur ces sujets et notamment sur
la communication digitale aucune
compétence encore une fois c'est pas mon
domaine et je fais incapable de savoir
ce qui est ce qui vaut un like plus que
notre like je ne sais pas du tout mais
en tout cas ça c'est le rôle
effectivement du pôle dit métier qui a
instruit les dossiers et qui doit
ensuite et qui connaît la matière en
plus surtout et qui doit effectivement
regarder un peu l'exécution et la
qualité de la prestation
il y a un autre contrôle et les deux se
rejoignent à un moment donné il y a un
autre contrôle qui est plutôt budgétaire
ou même franchement budgétaire et qui a
qui prend de forme
il y a une forme qui est conventionnelle
c'est à dire qui est dans la convention
attributive de subventions c'est
l'article je crois que c'est l'article 4
modèle de convention qu'on a utilisé
pour le format qui on utilise pour
l'ensemble des dossiers financés et qui
vise finalement à contrôler l'état
déclaratif de dépenses avant de délivrer
ce qu'on appelle le solde de la
subvention alors le soldat subvention
pour être tout à fait précis n'existe
que lorsqu'il y a ces fameuses
conventions au-delà de 23000 euros en
deçà de 23000 euros c'est la règle
budgétaire AE = CP je sais pas si vous
la connaissez mais
on délivre la totalité des engagements
et les crédits de paiement en même temps
donc ça c'est réglé c'est un acte
attribut à l'intérieur unilatéral donc
dans les conventions c'est différent
puisque effectivement un découpage en
deux
un acompte important 75% pour permettre
le lancement de l'action véritablement
et ensuite un contrôle sur deux
documents qui s'affigurent dans la
convention s'est indiqué noir sur blanc
dans un des articles c'est de ne pas une
attestation sur l'honneur du responsable
de l'association de la structure
financée qui indique que la structure a
atteint au moins un taux de 60% de
dépenses du budget prévisionnel qui
avait été fourni lors de la demande de
subvention
et un deuxième document qui est un
tableau que nous fournissons c'est un
autre tableau normalisé que nous
fournissons aux acteurs bien entendu
c'est pas eux qui le font qu'ils rédige
et on leur demande de remplir un tableau
ou apparaissent colonne de charge
comment dirais-je prévisionnel que l'on
charge réalisée colonne de produits
prévisionnels que l'on de produit
réalisé les montants qui permettent de
justifier mais c'est encore une fois
déclaratif le fameux taux de 60% du
budget de départ et c'est sur la base de
ces deux documents au moins de ces deux
documents que il peut être décidé qu'il
y a effectivement matière à délivrer le
fameux soldes de 25% qui reste à
délivrer voilà la première étape si vous
voulez mais qui est purement
conventionnelle parce que ce sont nos
conventions qui prévoient effectivement
ce premier contrôle
bien entendu
à ce niveau là à ce stade il n'y a pas
de contrôle sur pièce ces déclaratifs
sauf que enfin là je parle en tant que
pénaliste
quand l'association et son président
surtout signe une attestation sur
l'honneur indique qu'il a dépassé si
c'est pas la réalité ça peut poser quand
même un petit problème en matière pénale
donc on rappelle d'ailleurs les textes
du Code pénal sont indiqués que toutes
fausses déclaration peut entraîner
l'application des dispositions sur ce
qui sanctionne le faux et usage de faux
voilà on poursuit un peu je vais
peut-être vous solliciter un peu plus
sur finalement les les associations qui
selon vous ont posé problème donc je
parle bien du contrôle on est dans le
contrôle budgétaire
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire d'abord
il y en a donc 17 est-ce qu'il y en a 15
qui ne pose pas de problème budgétaire
ou est-ce que vous le dériez pas comme
ça et est-ce qu'il y en a deux
réellement qui posent un problème est-ce
que c'est vraiment de nature budgétaire
pour Liné pour l'autre ou est-ce que
c'est plus sur les contenus enfin etc
comment ça vous arrive c'est alors sur
les je termine quand même l'explication
parce que c'est un impact si je puis
dire un lien avec la question que vous
venez de poser ce que je viens de
décrire c'est un contrôle conventionnel
c'est-à-dire dispositif conventionnel
par contre il y a des dispositifs légal
et là c'est autre chose c'est l'article
10 de la loi du 12 avril 2000 sur les
relations entre les administrations et
les citoyens qui a des modifié plusieurs
reprises notamment 2014 c'est important
parce que c'est là qu'on définit
d'ailleurs pour la première fois dans la
loi française ce qu'est une subvention
en 2014 ce qui n'existait pas autrefois
et bien là cet article 10 prévoit que la
structure financée plutôt doit fournir
un document qui s'appelle le
compte-rendu financier le crfi et ça ça
doit se faire en principe en clôture
d'action donc là on a terminé l'action
on n'est pas en cours d'exécution comme
les 60% et j'ai pas par ailleurs là on
est à la fin de l'action et on doit
fournir un compte rendu financier qui
doit attester c'est ce qu'elle dit la
loi de la conformité de la dépense avec
la subvention telle qu'elle a été
accordée voilà mais simplement
déclaratif bien entendu à ce stade avec
les mêmes conséquences pénales que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure bien entendu parce
que tout ça c'est signé testé etc et
c'est un document là cette fois-ci qui
est imposé dans les dossiers de l'appel
du fond Marianne et documents que je
viens d'indiquer l'ensemble des
documents que je viens d'indiquer dans
l'ensemble je pense pouvoir le dire à
part deux mais à ce jour sauf erreur on
est encore dans les délais pour les
fournir en ce qui concerne le crfi on a
encore dans les délais
la totalité des documents que je viens
de citer ils sont dans les dossiers ils
ont été fournis donc il y a pas
véritablement de ce point de vue là une
alerte majeure il y a eu des retards ça
c'est exact mais pas une absence totale
de coopération de tel ou telle
association en revanche il y a
effectivement difficulté qui surgissent
sur Gérer sur le plan budgétaire je dis
bien une association qui est l'uspm
et là on est on est plus tard on est
alors je le dis clairement là aussi
autre difficulté sur cette association
le fameux compte-rendu financier doit
être fourni après la loi dans les six
mois de la clôture de l'exercice du
Jetair au cours duquel la subvention a
été accordée terme de la loi du 12 avril
2000 article 10 en réalité dans nos
conventions on est un peu plus exigeant
ça peut discuter d'ailleurs puisqu'on ne
laisse pas se délai là six mois après la
clôture des récits du thé en cours de
Canada on impose le versement de ce
document dans les six mois de
l'achèvement de l'action ce qui peut
être plus court finalement mais en tout
cas c'est discutable mais en tout cas
c'est très léger comme ça et en ce qui
concerne l'US oppm le point de départ
c'est un problème pour cette association
le point de départ du délai de six mois
a été considéré
peut-être à tort d'ailleurs comme étant
la date exacte du 31 mai 2022
et du coup c'est dans les six mois qu'on
aurait dû être fourni le fameux
compte-rendu financier d'après l'article
10 de la loi de 2000 et ce document en
2023 en février 2023 il était toujours
pas fourni
et donc c'est là où je parle de ce
budgétaire par rapport à cette
association c'est là où je vais
intervenir c'est en février 2023 c'est
avant d'ailleurs que n'éclate je lis bon
passons au passage mais quand même c'est
avant qu'une éclate effectivement
l'aspect public la difficulté avec ses
associations c'est exactement je crois
le 14 février 2023 où je suis alerté par
le pôle qui gère
Fuji de l'action donc le pôle métier qui
est lucidaire l'idée de contre-esco
républicain sachant que je l'ai pas dit
jusqu'à présent c'est ce pôle qui doit
recevoir les documents budgétaires avant
de les transmettre au pôle dont j'ai la
responsabilité c'est ce pôle là et ce
pôle là depuis cette ferme-là depuis
plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois
n'arrive pas à avoir la restitution des
documents demandés et donc le 14 février
c'est très précis parce que ça
correspond à des mails que j'ai envoyés
je suis alerté par le responsable de
chez Paul par le chef du pôle
en disant qu'ils ont des difficultés
avec l'uspm pour obtenir notamment le
compte-rendu financier
et donc je vais donner des éléments que
j'ai en tête parce que là ils sont assez
précis je téléphone j'arrive à trouver
le numéro de téléphone je téléphone au
Président
vous avez le nom je pense bien
j'arrive à l'avoir au téléphone alors
qu'il ne répondait pas au téléphone
semble-t-il précédemment à mes collègues
de l'autre vol je dis au passage et je
lui fais remarquer qu'effectivement on
n'a pas reçu le compte-rendu financier
mais surtout je découvre c'est là où il
y a effectivement une certaine
difficulté je découvre que les autres
documents qui ont été fournis je pense
alors je ne sais pas exactement la date
mais c'était en 2022 ça c'est sûr qui
sont l'état des dépenses qui auraient pu
justifier le cas échéant le versement du
solde puisque ils auraient pu justifier
qu'ils avaient atteint 60% des fameuses
dépenses en fait ces documents ont bien
été fournis mais il révèle que ce seuil
de 60% n'a jamais été atteint jamais
et donc lors de la conversation
téléphonique je fais état de cet aspect
là avec le président et je lui explique
en l'état c'est pas possible de verser
le solde il n'a pas rempli les
conditions conventionnelles et donc je
lui demande ensuite alors ça fait
l'objet d'un écrit de ma part parce que
je couvre évidemment on appelle
téléphone par un mail et je demande de
ma transmettre le fameux compte-rendu
financier qu'il aurait dû fournir au
moins depuis novembre 2022 et que le
pôle les collègues du pôle métier
n'arrive pas à obtenir et je lui fais
enfin je lui fais remarquer par écrit
que en l'état l'action est en terminée
de toute façon elle est terminée on ne
pourra pas verser le solde ça sera pas
possible et je lui demande même de
renoncer expressément pour couvrir tout
risque de contentieux parce que c'est
jamais ça peut parfois être le cas et
c'est ce qu'il va faire il va envoyer le
compte rendu financier je crois le
lendemain ça doit être le 15 février
avec effectivement de sa part un
indication sur laquelle il renonce à
tenir le sol donc là il y a un problème
budgétaire c'est clair donc si vous nous
dites s'il y a eu un retard si je peux
dire à l'allumage entre novembre aurait
dû être la fin de la Convention et
février vous intervenez c'est parce que
le pôle métier finalement vous dit j'ai
quelques difficultés mais ça va arriver
enfin bon je sais pas et en tout cas ça
vous renvoie à février où ils vous
disent là on n'y arrive pas c'est ça le
sujet exactement bon ok
par contre sur les au niveau des
contrôles vous amenez un sur une autre
association qui s'appelle Civic Fab et
finalement c'est la première association
sur laquelle vous allez faire un
contrôle un peu approfondie c'est comme
ça qu'il faut lire les choses donc ce
qu'il pouvait nous étonner c'est de
finalement entre
deux associations l'une qui avait des
problèmes financiers que vous relevez en
février 2023 et la deuxième qui avait
des problèmes de contenu sur lequel il y
avait une difficulté qui ont dû
transpirer jusqu'à votre service ni même
c'est à dire
l'association
sur le commun je perds toujours son nom
reconstruire le commun
malgré tous ces pas ces deux
associations là qui font l'objet d'un
contrôle c'est ça mais c'est plutôt la
troisième que je viens de citer
est-ce que est-ce que tout ça est quand
même assez logique finalement dans votre
esprit alors logique pas toujours en
discuter mais en fait civique Fab a posé
une autre difficulté qui était alors
qu'il n'apparaît pas peut-être éligible
mais en tout cas que j'ai rencontré
c'est que là aussi à partir des lectures
des documents budgétaires transmis par
cette association il apparaissait que on
n'aurait pas dû verser le solde de
l'association toujours
j'avais donné des instructions pour ne
pas le faire sauf que bon ben si c'était
trop sur le sujet mais par
une action malencontreuse dans des
agents enfin de mon poste j'en parlerai
responsabilité c'est clair en fait ce
soit la bien été versée et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle quand a arrive pour
la première fois à nouveau responsable
du contrat d'atte financier en 7 ans
2022 en novembre 2022 ensemble on
regarde les dossiers qui posent
difficultés et comme j'avais indiqué par
écrit que contenu de cette versement il
y aurait matière à contrôler cette
association qui s'appelle anxivique Fab
elle est retenue parmi trois
associations d'ailleurs pour faire
l'objet d'un contrôle approfondi il y en
a il y en a deux autres il y a pas que
c'est une femme également une
association on parle pas ici c'est la
raison de pourquoi les tempêtes
notre question alors on va poursuivre
alors peut-être avant on a une ou deux
questions sur un verremeiller c'est sur
cette partie là
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Lafitte j'aimerais savoir puisque le
montant des subventions en tout cas pour
les deux associations concernées dépasse
153000 euros est-ce que vous avez
vérifié qu'un commissaire au compte
avait été nommé est-ce que dans la
procédure de contrôle vous avez vérifié
ça ce qu'il y avait un commissaire aux
comptes et ce que vous avez eu des
échanges par rapport à ça alors
commissaire aux comptes en principe oui
enfin dans les documents qu'on demande
effectivement il y a soit comment
dirais-je l'obligation de verser
notamment quand on dépasse 153000 euros
de verser les les comptes annuels et le
bilan sous forme du plan comptable
associatif
plus effectivement le rapport du
commissaire augmente alors normalement
c'est dossiers comportent ces documents
là je peux pas affirmer parce que je
vais pas en tête à la totalité du
contenu de chacun des dossiers mais
normalement la plupart en tout cas de
ces dossiers comporte ces éléments là
par contre en dessous de 253000 euros
les associations n'ont pas l'obligation
de dé poser leurs comptes et un simple
état financier est exigé ce qui est
aussi le cas d'un certain nombre
d'associations mais en revanche
effectivement la validation par le
commissaire aux comptes de mémoire enfin
elle doit figurer j'espère en tout cas
dans la plupart des dossiers je peux pas
l'affirmer je ne garantirai pas
sincèrement mais en tout cas c'est à
contrôler parce qu'on n'a pas vérifier
spécialement dans les investigations
d'ailleurs ça aurait pu être fait en
complément mais en tout cas moi je pense
que certains d'entre eux en tout cas moi
je les ai vus figures effectivement dans
les dossiers je peux pas affirmer qu'ils
sont dans tous les cas
merci
je vais revenir à l'usé ppm donc vous
nous avez vous avez bien évoqué votre
action et réaction du 14 février 2023
qui est suivi un mois après
[Musique]
d'une d'un contact que vous avez avec
cette association pour
l'informer de ce qu'elle va avoir un
contrôle sur pièce donc
ça vous paraît vous les informer donc là
je dirais très rapidement eu égard aux
éléments vous nous avez donné déjà pour
l'engression liée à l'avenant parce que
vous pensez que
enfin vous avez certainement des doutes
sur comment dirais-je le fonctionnement
de l'association c'est ça et des doutes
et même des craintes en fait ce qui
s'est passé il y a une autre étape entre
ces deux étapes si je puis dire qui se
situent en jeu culadat mais je crois que
c'est aux alentours du 14 mars il me
semble c'est que nous avons reçu enfin
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure le fameux
compte-rendu financier donc on l'a entre
les mains etc sauf que en lui disant je
note que une première partie dans ces
documents c'est les documents de
formalisés c'est normalisé ce sont des
cerfs donc il attache chapitre il faut
remplir c'est tout simple enfin en tout
cas c'est extrêmement contraignant quand
même pour l'association dans la
rédaction et il y a une partie qui est
la première partie qui n'est pas remplie
qui est le bilan tout simplement le
bilan de l'action
il n'y a pas de mention il y a un budget
enfin budget final qui apparaît des
quelques commentaires mais la première
partie n'est pas rempli et donc je
renvoie un mail en disant bah attendez
je suis désolé mais il manque le bilan
le bilan quelle quantitatif voir
qualitatif qui doit figurer là-dedans et
donc ça c'est je répète aux alentours du
14 mars 15 mars ou 14 mars et
il n'y a pas de réponse au bout de je
sais plus quelques jours trois quatre
jours aucune réponse et c'est là que
j'envoie alors cette fois-ci un deuxième
troisième ou quatrième mais je sais plus
où j'indique effectivement constatant
l'absence de réponse et en plus d'autres
documents n'ont pas été fournis
notamment les bilans les bilans le
rapport au commissaire aux comptes nous
n'avons pas les bilans 2021 nous l'ont
pas les bilans 2022 ce que je l'ai
demandé puisque l'exercice s'est étalé
sur deux exercices budgétaires
et bien c'est là que j'indique que vu
ces éléments ces absences d'éléments
c'est un contrôle sur pièce qui va être
déclenché en application de l'article 8
de la Convention d'accord donc le
comment dirais-je l'absence d'éléments
concernant le bilan d'action qui est
le rendu objectif par l'association
elle-même donc ça confirme c'est ce qui
déclenche votre réaction puisque
d'ailleurs vous aviez donc vous
confirmez là que le bilan quand il tâtif
et qualitatif insuffisance que vous
aviez noté donc si
d'aventure il était dit que le bilan de
cette association à ce moment-là est bon
voire positif
quel serait votre réaction vous
confirmeriez que
inexact enfin moi je peux pas affirmer
quoi que ce soit sur le fond parce que
c'est pas quelque chose que je maîtrise
très précisément encore une fois on est
dans un domaine qui est relativement
formel qui sont des tableaux à remplir
des documents formalisés également des
indications de tête portée par contre le
contenu même de l'action là il faut
effectivement associer forcément des
personnes qui sont en face chez nous qui
sont plus à même de donner une
appréciation ça concerne cette
association sans concerne aussi une
autre manifestement et là moi j'ai pas
forcément de regard à porter en revanche
ça concerne plutôt l'autre association
que l'USPPM si la réalisation de
l'action s'est écartée de l'objet même
qui avait été défini dans la convention
là il y a ma terre à remettre en cause
l'attribution la subvention c'est un
autre sujet ça et dans le cas de l'ucpm
c'est un problème budgétaire
c'est-à-dire qu'encore une fois même
s'ils avaient rempli correctement le
fameux bilan dans la partie 1 du compte
rendu financier ça n'aurait rien changé
au non versement du solde puisque de
toute façon le principe il y a une rempl
issait pas les conditions
conventionnelles
d'accord je veux peut-être juste dans là
encore dans l'exécution financière
donc on voit bien que cette association
présente finalement
plusieurs signes d'inquiétude et
l'annonce un soutien une subvention de
la Région
des régions pardon de 145.000 euros
d'aide privée autour de 45000 euros on
voit bien que un certain nombre de
charges sont sous exécutés qui a donc
toujours pas de personnel pardon et qui
en fait plus que des charges de
personnel puisqu'elles atteignent au
global une exécution à 87% en 2022
est-ce que finalement
ça rejoint le la question que j'ai posée
avant est-ce que le bilan de
l'association c'est pas surtout des
charges de personnel
alors en soi je crois qu'il faut quand
même être un peu distancé par rapport
aux éléments d'alerte si je puis dire de
ces associations là ou telle ou tel en
soit le fait de payer du personnel pour
travailler sur des réseaux sociaux ce
n'est pas forcément choquant en soi
il peut y avoir des achats de matériel
c'est sûr il peut y avoir des
imputations de charges fixe la location
d'un local une partie d'assurance qu'il
faut assurer qui peut être imputé c'est
tout à fait régulier sur une partie de
l'action en tout cas ça ce que dans un
montant raisonnable et adapté à la
charge que représente pour l'association
la réalisation c'est tout à fait normal
et encore une fois les charges de
personnel elles étaient présentes je
crois de mémoire dès le début dans le de
la demande subvention il y avait une
indication assez précise d'ailleurs sur
des recrutements de personnes de
salariés alors de mémoire c'était froid
six personnes dans la dernière version
du document qu'on avait reçu il devait y
avoir deux contrats à durer indéterminés
les noms ne figureraient pas une figure
jamais d'ailleurs dans les demandes de
subventions jamais il y a des noms de
personnel s à l'autre côté bien entendu
mais par contre il y avait deux contrats
duré indéterminés et je crois 4 durées à
contrat déterminées donc c'était pas
forcément choquant qu'une large partie
de la subvention servent à je sais pas
moi recruter des community managers ou
que sais-je c'était pas forcément le cas
par contre on avait encore une fois pas
les noms enfin moi j'avais pas les noms
évidemment des personnes qui allaient
être recruter à ce stata et puis surtout
moi j'avais pas un sweet de dossier à ce
stade donc je n'avais pas forcément une
connaissance précise de ce qui allait
ensuite générer les charges mais elles
étaient pas incohérentes
d'accord juste une très courte question
vous avez déjà quelques enseignements
début d'évaluation sur le contrôle que
vous avez lancé à la mi-mars de cette
année
alors il y a des documents nombreux qui
ont été fournis je veux dire ils ont été
fournis pour les analyser après c'est à
peu près de plus de 200 documents qui
ont été envoyés par transfert peu
importe
pour le moment je peux pas faire grand
chose
il y a des bulletins de salaire nombreux
alors moi j'avais là je suis parti
maintenant des services mais j'avais
demandé quand je satisfait de contexte
des bulletins de salaire mais connaît
aussi les contrats de travail alors ça
moi je les ai pas vu je le dis
franchement je ne les ai pas je les ai
pas vu en tout cas j'avais demandé quand
les demandes en plus et donc j'imagine
que ça va être fait les bulletins de
salaire certains oui sont effectivement
manifestement en lien avec des
personnalités
identifiées dans l'association enfin
deux personnalités avec des montants de
l'ordre j'ai regardé enfin j'ai pas les
noms mais en tout cas on voit apparaître
les montants dans la il y a un tableau
synoptique aussi on voit classer par
année la totalité des charges puisque
dans la convention enfin je le dis au
passage il y a une exigence
supplémentaire au-delà des contrôles
c'est d'avoir un outil analytique c'est
l'article aussi je crois de la
convention qui prévoit un outil
analytique et effectivement
l'association nous a restitués des
tableaux Excel où on voit par année par
classé par catégorie des montants
différentes charges à vérifier ce que ça
correspond bien à l'action qu'on a fait
ça c'est autre chose et donc on voit
apparaître des montants de salaire de
l'ordre de 3000 je crois un peu plus de
3000 euros pour les plus importants il y
en a deux manifestement et un autre un
peu plus important qui doit être lors de
3900 ou 3500 € je crois sur plusieurs
mois et ça débute à partir de juin dès
qu'on a délivré finalement les premiers
crédits de paiement quand les a consommé
donc en juin 2021 on voit apparaître
effectivement ces bulletins de salaire
dans les tableaux qu'on a obtenus voilà
mais après il faut quand même vérifier
évidemment tout le reste qu'il s'agit
très bien merci quelques questions pour
reconstruire le commun alors des choses
d'abord très simples il y a eu des
réunions il y a eu des réunions en
particulier sur les contenus il y a eu
des discussions sur les contenus
éventuellement des messages soi-disant
politique ou reconnus d'ailleurs comme
nature politique est-ce que vous avez
été associé à cette à ce travail-là
cette réflexion là ou pas du tout alors
pas exactement sur cette forme mais par
contre et ça c'est important il y a une
réunion à laquelle on m'a demandé de
participer alors j'ai du mal à la situer
pour moi elle est en mars 2022 mais avec
quelques nuances je pense que c'est ça
ou effectivement la question de comment
dirais-je de la qualité du produit en
quelque sorte
l'aspect politique enfin moi j'ai pas du
tout souvenir que cet aspect était
abordé alors peut-être manière incidente
mais c'était pas le sujet le sujet à
cette époque là c'était une faible
pénétration finalement sur les réseaux
sociaux un nombre d'adhésion d'adhérents
faible et finalement une problématique
finalement plutôt de pénétration sur les
réseaux sociaux de qualité du produit
sur ce terrain là et la question qui
était posée c'était de savoir si on
pouvait remettre en cause le montant de
la subvention c'est compliqué parce que
l'acte est en signé il faudrait
véritablement qu'on s'écarte totalement
du produit tel qu'il avait été défini
l'objet même de la Convention et surtout
alors ça c'est un autre aspect et ça
montre la difficulté justement en amont
c'est à dire relatif absence de
méthodologie de contrôle en amont au
moment de la prise de décès avant la
prise de décision c'est que dans la
rubrique de la Convention il y a une
partie qui s'appelle les critères
d'évaluation
or ces critères qui ont été acceptés
puisque c'est un document qui est le
CERFA qui est dupliqué un joli
clairement c'est du copier-coller
c'est-à-dire que quand on fait on met en
forme l'acte attributif sauf difficulté
majeure repérer on reprend les termes de
la du CERFA qui est la demande de
subvention et on l'intègre en annexe
dans la convention elle-même donc on
reprend les termes or dans la partie
concernant les critères d'évaluation les
termes qui ont été acceptés donc le 21
mai 2020
sont je dirais relativement vague voire
très vague j'ai le souvenir notamment il
y a dans les critères il y a un critère
qui s'appelle
évaluation de qualitative
et la traduction dans la convention
c'est évaluation qualitative
évidemment avec des
critères de cette nature c'est
extrêmement compliqué de remettre en
cause le non respect de l'évaluation
telle qu'elle est prévue à la Convention
donc j'avais dit à cette réunion j'ai
dit que c'était un peu compliqué qu'il
fallait faire suivre l'évolution mais
que ça me paraissait difficile de
remettre en cause le principe même de la
subvention qui avait été accordé avec un
acte signé et des parties on risquait un
contentieux là ça m'en délicat donc à ce
stade là on en est resté là mais encore
une fois j'ai pas du tout le souvenir
alors je répète ça pu être évoqué de
manière incidente mais c'était pas le
sable le sujet majeur j'ai pas le
souvenir que des aspects alors par
contre de contenu politique ait été le
point central des échanges à ce
moment-là mars 2022
après il y a eu d'autres échanges mais
moi j'ai découvert par la suite je le
dis là j'ai pas été associé
effectivement cet aspect là surgit de
manière beaucoup plus nette et là j'ai
pas été directement associé très bien et
donc suite à votre raisonnement
je suis votre raisonnement qui
finalement les 25% qui restaient ont été
vers
globalement les conditions financières
étaient remplies administratives on va
dire
le sujet est un peu ténu
sur la question de fond est-ce que c'est
et donc bon on paye quoi et finalement
après une fois avoir payé tout ça et
avoir constaté des difficultés qui se
poursuivaient on demande le
remboursement pour le remboursement
c'est le rapporteur qui va y venir
vous pouvez estimer à ce stade quel
montant quel est le montant de la
réclamation ou de retour que vous
attendez d'abord la procédure en fait
dans les conventions mais c'est pour une
partie de la traduction de terme
budgétaire classique il y a deux
méthodes
soit la méthode vers un peu brutale qui
est l'émission d'un titre de perception
c'est-à-dire que l'État émet un type de
perception en raison d'un à l'issue
d'une procédure contradictoire parce que
attention là aussi il faut respecter
qu'un certain nombre de formes on ne
fait pas cela sans recevoir les
observations de la partie adverse si je
puis dire il y a une deuxième méthode
mais ce qui n'est pas qui n'a pas
vocation à mon sens à être utilisé qu'on
a utilisé parfois pour éviter les
missions de l'équipe de perception et
toute la posture très lourde qui va
derrière
j'ai expérimenté il y a quelques mois ça
a été extrêmement compliqué je le dis au
passage en fait on a un le
trop-perçu calcule notre perçu on a pu
se trop perçu sur le montant de la
subvention
s'il y a un renouvellement qui va venir
l'année suivante et donc on réduit
finalement le montant et c'est prévu
dans un des articles de la Convention
c'est prévu expressément bon là c'est
pas le cas dans le cadre qu'on évoque
évidemment on est sur le terme classique
a priori de l'émission de type de
perception alors pour le moment à ce
stade je ne peux pas vous indiquer quel
est le montant qui va faire l'objet d'un
restitution au profit de l'État ce qui
est demandé enfin ce qui est envisagé en
tout cas quand je quitter le service
mais en tout cas c'était la dernière
étape quand j'étais là j'étais présent
c'était de calculer très précisément le
coût qu'a représenté et l'imputation
surtout budgétaire qui a représenté pour
la subvention toutes les prestations qui
se sont écartées de l'objet de la
Convention et a priori d'après les
échanges alors pour l'instant informel
que j'ai eu avec des collègues qui
travaillent plus en lien avec les
réseaux sociaux donc la fameuse ucdr
c'est a priori calculable parce que ils
ont dans la convention je crois que ça
fasse dans la dans les documents fournis
budgétaire une association au tout
départ il y a des montants par
prestation et donc on sait qu'une vidéo
coûte temps etc alors je sais plus quel
est mon temps je vois ces 6000 euros par
vidéo ou je ne sais trop donc on doit
être en mesure à ce stade de calculer
précisément dans un cas de
contradictoire parce qu'il va falloir le
notifier il faudra recevoir les
observations de la partie adverse et moi
j'ai lancé la procédure en ce sens
récemment avec une courrier recommandée
qui est parti je croyable trois quatre
jours et où effectivement on va recevoir
les observations de la partie adverse
sur ce montant et pour l'instant à mon
sens il n'est pas encore calculé
très bien merci alors j'ai Isabelle
briquet puis
Daniel Joyet
une petite question on a évoqué tout à
l'heure là la subvention de 39000 euros
enfin verser fin 2020 enfin plutôt de
billes début 2021 et
lors des de la présentation de cette
de cette subvention quand on a commencé
à parler du fond Marianne et tout il a
été le secrétaire général
a dit que cette subvention avait été
versée enfin alors fin d'année 2020 peu
importe à la limite pour accompagner le
lancement de cette de cette association
l'association étant reconstruire le
commun
cependant enfin le choix de financer la
création d'une association s'inscrit
quand même en contradiction avec le
principe même du fond
interministériel de prévention de la
délinquance qui vise à financer des
projets et pas directement les
structures ainsi les il est stipulé dans
les différents documents et formulaires
que la prise en charge des frais de
structure ne peut dépasser 10% des
frangins par les associations donc la
question est double sur cette subvention
39000 euros qu'est-ce qui a pu justifier
la dérogation faite au profit de
reconstruire en commun pour cette
subvention 39000 et pour la suite sur le
fond Marianne les subventions apportées
aussi bien à reconstruire le commun
calu c'est l'ucpm
ont-elles ou non couvert une part
supérieure à 10% des charges de
fonctionnement administratifs des deux
associations enfin d'autres termes
est-ce qu'on a financé des projets ou
bien des structures associatives
au passage que j'essaie de rappeler
souvent parce que il y a souvent une
certaine confusion sur le rôle du fond
ministériel qui est c'est pas tout à
fait des crédits tu le réhabituels
sache que parce qu'effectivement c'est
important de le rappeler le fond
interministériel est défini dans son
objet par la loi ce qui est pas le cas
de tous les programmes budgétaires de
l'État il y a pas une loi spéciale par
programme et là il y a une loi l'article
5 de la loi du 5 mars 2016 qui dit
qu'effectivement le FIPD le fond
interministériel finance des actions de
prévention de la délinquance de
prévention de la radicalisation depuis
ça a été un peu élargi mais ce sont des
actions ou des projets et ça c'est un
point important alors je n'ai pas
assisté
au moment où cadre dans lequel a été
décidé cette fameuse subvention 39000
euros je ne sais pas comment ça c'est
déroulé puisque je répète j'ai pas
trouvé de trace en tout cas des
conditions en tout cas la convention
elle a bien été signée passée ce qui est
sûr c'est que au-delà du fonctionnement
moi je pense que c'est pas exactement
comme ça quelque chose se présentent
dans la convention que j'ai lu j'ai lu
je sais pas si elle vous a été adressée
j'ai un doute d'ailleurs mais c'est pas
le fonctionnement de l'action enfin de
l'association qui décrite comme étant
l'objet de la subvention c'est la
création d'un site internet avec des
contenus qui sont listés qui sont
indiqués alors après reste à savoir ce
qui a été réellement fait ça c'est autre
chose mais en tout cas c'est bien une
action qui est décrite dans la
convention à ça je vais vérifier voilà
donc pour moi c'était plutôt
formellement je dis bien formellement
plutôt régulier voilà c'est une action
faite dans le cadre du lancement d'une
association tourner comme ça très bien
Daniel broyer
merci bonjour monsieur la fidjg en fait
j'ai deux questions la première c'est
est-ce fréquent d'attribuer une
subvention continue une convention avec
une association qui n'a pas d'existence
préalable
enfin j'avoue j'étais mère 20 ans
qui n'avaient pas fait une preuve
préalable de son action de sa
constitution et donc je comprends sur
cette association qu'au fond on
accompagne sa création est-ce que j'ai
mal compris les les propos ou est-ce que
c'est exact et ma deuxième question vous
nous avez décrit avec rigueur un
processus
d'élaboration et de questionnements pour
vos collaborateurs sur le suivi des
attributions de subventions des analyses
de dossiers de subventions très élaborée
et vous nous avez indiqué que en 2020 de
mémoire le cabinet de Madame siapa fait
remonter à son niveau l'attribution de
subventions est-ce que les le cabinet
dans ce cas là est soumis à au suivi de
des procédures qui ont été définies par
votre direction
alors sur
la deuxième question si vous permettez
en fait le document qui faisait
référence à l'époque quand l'appel à
projet a été lancé c'était un document
qui datait de 2019
vous n'avait pas été remis à jour
c'est un document qui datait donc de
2019 qui n'avait pas été remis à jour et
donc le cabinet ministériel n'apparaît
pas dans ce document c'est toute la
difficulté donc quand en avril 2021
semble-t-il pour la première fois le
cabinet ministériel fait élever à son
niveau la prise de décision le document
qui fait référence n'est pas à jour je
le dis clairement il l'est aujourd'hui
je l'ai mis à jour il y a quelques jours
avec une note de service interne on a
totalement revu le document mais encore
une fois c'est la situation de 2021
voilà il n'est pas impliqué dans le
dispositif puisqu'il n'existe pas encore
dans ce document là en 2019
ensuite la première question que vous
aviez posé qui concernait le lancement
enfin en tout cas l'accompagnement de
l'association moi j'ai pas l'observation
à faire j'ai pas participé à cette prise
de décision je constate qu'il y a une
convention qui a été signée le 28
décembre 2020 une association et c'est
pour ça que j'ai fait un mail d'ailleurs
en ce sens on a dit quand que je
m'étonnais de la brièveté de d'existence
de cette association pour lui attribuer
non pas 39000 euros mais 330
000 35 voilà bon c'est tout ce que je
peux dire je constate cette situation
voilà elle vient de se créer je crois en
octobre il me semble 2020 et en décembre
elle reçoit 39000 euros et en avril elle
reçoit 300 quelques 1000 euros voilà
c'est la situation merci ça apporte
Jeanne dernière parce que comme je
voulais juste revenir sur pour bien
comprendre
vous nous avez dit que le fond Marianne
l'attribution des subventions ce qui
relevait avant comment dirige dans la
décision du comité à l'arrivée de la
ministre ça avait été il avait été
décidé que ça passe de compétences
ministérielles c'est ça vous paraissait
où ça vous paraît encore aujourd'hui
justifier il y avait selon vous vous
pensez où vous avez entendu
comment dirais-je le des raisons pour
expliquer ce changement parce que on
pourrait penser que les sommes ne sont
pas selon les cas parfois on les trouve
très élevés
comparativement et au regard des
responsabilités est-ce que ça vous
paraît bien que ça relève directement de
d'une décision de ministérielle bon moi
j'ai pas juger des décisions
ministérielles bien entendu mais il y a
effectivement des éléments je dirais qui
interroge enfin en tout cas qui peuvent
soulever un certain nombre de débats sur
ce sujet
lors de la terre de la dépense par
exemple qui est lors de la terre de la
dépense ce secrétaire général c'est lui
qui est responsable du bop les budgets
opérationnel de le programme et c'est
lui qui signe des actes attributifs
c'est son statut c'est pas la ministre
c'est pas les actes attributifs voilà ça
c'est une réalité budgétaire après ce
qui est quand même assez il faut bien
l'avoir en tête cet aspect là je crois
c'est qu'en 2020 il y a un changement
assez radical dans les liaisons
ministères administration si je puis
dire c'est que c'est la première fois je
pense ne pas me tromper qu'un ministre
qu'une ministre en espèces a épouse
exactement les compétences de notre
service c'est à dire que ça son décret
l'attribution
quand je dis d'épouse c'est pas tout à
fait exact parce que c'est compétences
déborde elle traite aussi de la
citoyenneté mais aussi surtout de
l'asile je crois de l'immigration enfin
je ne sais plus en tout cas c'est pas le
taux de compétences mais n'empêche que
nos compétences sont totalement définies
dans le décret d'attribution de la
ministre donc ça veut dire que le lien
est très fort pour la première fois
entre un ministre ou une ministre et un
service administratif qui c'est vrai
parfois est un du mal à qualifier
exactement j'essayais PDR c'est quelque
chose sur laquelle parfois on
s'interroge aussi sur ces missions
qu'est-ce qu'il fait le j'essaie PDR il
distribue des crédits mais il faut pas
que ça il est d'abord des politiques il
rédigent des stratégies nationales les
gens c'est quelque chose parce que j'en
ai rédigé une voilà et là on a un
ministre qui est très en lien
directement avec nos attributions il y a
notre aspect aussi alors qui est très
humain si je peux dire mais ça je pense
l'explication est là vraisemblablement
mais ça n'a rien à voir avec l'aspect
administratif au budgétaire c'est qu'en
fait lorsque le cabinet se met en place
en 2020 le cabinet madame Schiappa
deux collègues à nous qui étaient
membres du secrétariat général monte au
cabinet et que bien entendu ils ont
participé eux au comité de programmation
précédent ils connaissent le mécanisme
ils connaissent la gestion du Bd ils ont
eu à y travailler et à participer au
comité et donc je pense que c'est
probablement là l'explication je peux
pas l'affirmer je garderai bien d'être
affirmatif mais je vois quelque chose
d'assez logique c'est qu'ils ont
expliqué comment fonctionnait la gestion
des crédits centraux du FIPD et que
évidemment le cabinet ministériel a
peut-être trouvé logique qu'à un moment
donné et puis savoir Un Certain Regard
politique parce que ça a des incidences
évidemment on comprend bien sur l'usage
des crédits d'État
j'avais fait juste une dernière question
très technique quand on parle du seuil
de 60% pour obtenir le complément de
subvention c'est 60%, il faut justifier
de 60% de la consommation de la
subvention ou de 60% de programme c'est
60% en fait des dépenses prévisionnelles
dans la demande de subvention
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait dans la demande
il y a voilà je sais pas moi il peut y
avoir qu'une partie financée par la
subvention heureusement
[Musique]
merci beaucoup monsieur Lafitte merci
d'avoir encore une fois
patienté
dans la première étape et merci pour
tout ce que vous avez amené chers
collègues merci de votre patience
également